dialing in from london it was a message
to a global audience
only some able to gather in paris for
the one planet summit
the prince convinced that kovid 19 has
shown the world
must and can act now on climate change
consensus and intention goals and
targets
are only the first steps the only
possible solution
to the challenges facing our planet lies
in working
in harmony with nature's own economy
rather than against it
this is his new idea i am launching the
terror carter
as the basis of a recovery plan for
nature
people and planet
at this historic tipping point
with the lives and livelihoods of
present and future generations in mind
a call to action to big business
industry
and the financial world the terra carter
just like the magna carta
a defining set of principles and rights
but this time
commitments to nature and a recovery
plan for the planet
brian moynihan is the ceo of bank of
america one of the founding partners
most companies agree that this is where
they got to go i think society has to
help encourage them it should be a
series of carrots and the theories of
go and the people are doing it best
should be encouraged to do more and that
will lead other people there
as opposed to sticks saying you know
don't do this or don't do that because
in the end of the day that will stop
maybe one participant
but we've got to have a broader avenue
where everybody comes
because you need the entire capital
system to align to make this happen
the likes of bp heathrow hsbc
and astrazeneca have also already signed
up
and committed to a 10 billion dollar
fund to invest
in green initiatives campaigner tony
juniper
has worked with the prince on a number
of projects
there is no profit to be made on a dying
planet
ecosystem degradation mass extinction
climatic heating
depletion of resources these are not
separate
to business they are fundamentally
connected
the prince sees this as a tipping point
a time when the private sector
needs to lead so our children and
grandchildren don't just look back
on broken promises rhiannon mills sky
news